[Musique]
toutes ces personnes ont un point en
commun elle travaille dans les centres
d'expertise et décès de la Direction
générale de l'armement la DGA une entité
clé du ministère des armées dans ce
journal de la défense nous vous emmenons
à la rencontre d'hommes et femmes au
savoir-faire unique exceptionnellement
nous avons pu suivre leur travail dans
ces lieux singuliers rarement ouvert au
public
la DGA est créée par le général de
Gaulle en 1961 un an plus tôt la France
se dote de l'arme nucléaire
la politique extérieure de la Cinquième
République se veut plus indépendante et
plus volontariste de cette façon le
général de Gaulle entame une
transformation en profondeur du paysage
de l'armement français
nous avons décidé d'avoir ce qu'il nous
faut et d'autant mieux et d'autant plus
que cette puissance nucléaire comme on
dit
est lié directement
à l'énergie atomique elle-même qui est
comme vous le savez tous
le fond de l'activité de demain
la force nucléaire devient alors un
enjeu stratégique et prioritaire pour la
France la DGA tient son socle si la
France fait partie des grandes
puissances mondiales notamment sur le
plan militaire c'est parce que la DGA a
su développer des programmes d'armement
ambitieux tout en anticipant les
conflits de demain
ces missions c'est d'équiper les forces
armées et de préparer le futur de notre
défense concrètement c'est 10500 hommes
et femmes ingénieurs civils militaire
technicien qui sont
disséminées sur l'ensemble du territoire
puisque nous avons une dizaine de
centres d'expertise et d'essais
dans le sud de la France un drôle
d'oiseau navigue dans les airs à
proximité du Mont Ventoux
à bord de cet avion des personnels de la
DGA le commandant Guillaume et
l'ingénieur de l'armement Magali réalise
des tests en vol
pendant plusieurs jours le binôme qui a
suivi une des formations les plus
exigeantes au sein de la prestigieuse et
Colette nerfs enchaîne les vols et en
exploitent les données pour améliorer
l'aéronef sur lequel il travaille le
Rafale F4
le Rafale est un des avions de chasse
emblématique de la France au début des
années 1980 l'armée de l'air et la
Marine nationale ont besoin de
renouveler leur flots vieillissante avec
un nouvel avion de combat capable de
remplir plusieurs types de missions
l'industriel Dassault Aviation travaille
alors sur l'élaboration de ce
biaisacteur
en 1991 il fait l'objet d'un vol de
démonstration à l'occasion du Salon du
Bourget
le Rafale intègre le service actif au
début des années 2000 avec comme premier
standard opérationnel le Rafale F1
au cours de ces 20 dernières années la
DGA n'a eu de cesse de l'améliorer le
Rafale F2 succède rapidement au F1 et
intègre la capacité de frapposol
le F3 bénéficie ensuite d'une évolution
de ses réacteurs d'une meilleure
furtivité ainsi que d'une capacité
d'emport de missile dernier cri
le chasseur est mobilisé sur plusieurs
théâtres d'opérations en Afghanistan en
Libye au Mali et en Syrie
cela fait 4 ans maintenant que le
personnel de la DGA travaille sur un
nouveau standard le Rafale F4
ces améliorations doivent permettre à
l'avion français d'entrer dans l'air du
numérique depuis le début de l'année un
premier appareil est soumis à de
nombreux tests
sur la base aérienne d'Istres le
personnel navigant du centre DGA et ses
envol s'apprête justement à l'éprouver
ce sont des experts du domaine
aéronautique et ils explorent les
limites des avions ainsi que de leurs
équipements
nous mettons nos pilotes ou nos
personnels naviguant DC qui sont
ingénieurs ou techniciens abordent des
aéronefs nous les mettons dans des
situations très risquées donc ça leur
demande et ça demande aux processus
qu'on met en place de la rigueur de
l'agilité de l'autonomie beaucoup de
lucidité
nous travaillons actuellement sur
l'arrivée du standard f4.1 du Rafale qui
est le dernier standard développé
actuellement on fait un focus
particulier sur le viseur de casque qui
est une des capacités nouvelles du
standard f4.1 donc c'est un casque porté
par le pilote qui comporte une petite
lame qui vient descendre devant l'oeil
du pilote et sur laquelle on vient
projeter des symboles donc c'est des
symboles qui peuvent porter sur des de
la navigation donc des paramètres de vol
et des à se repérer dans l'espace ça
peut être aussi des symboles qui sont
plaqués sur l'environnement donc par
exemple ils vont entourer un avion dans
l'environnement ou un objectif sur le
sol et ça peut aussi permettre d'envoyer
la direction du regard du pilote dans le
système d'attaque du Rafale donc les
relève c'est le Rafale b359 c'est un f41
donc pour ça il y a une constellation de
petites pastilles qu'on pose sur la
verrière on appelle ça des filles du
ciel les fiduciales et le dialogues de
manière optique avec le casque qui a une
petite caméra avec des centrales à
inertie et ça permet comme ça de repérer
euh en tout temps la position de la tête
du pilote dans le cockpit et donc
d'afficher les symboles correctement et
on va vérifier en particulier la
précision de la ligne de visée du casque
donc on va par exemple viser des points
des points au sol donc par exemple hier
on a visé l'antenne au sommet du Mont
Ventoux ensuite dans la conduite de
l'essai vraiment dans le vol c'est un
peu la même chose on a absolument
complémentaire le pilote lui amène
l'avion dans les points les positions
les éléments de vol qui sont nécessaires
pour le recueil des données et
l'ingénieur lui valide donc ce qu'on
appelle point d'essai est-ce qu'il a eu
oui ou non tous les résultats qui
étaient nécessaires pour ensuite pouvoir
passer à la suite et pouvoir avoir tout
ce qu'il nous faudra au débriefing pour
pouvoir exploiter le maximum de chaque
vol d'essai
c'est un casque avec lequel on adore
voler pourquoi parce qu'il démultiplie
les capacités vraiment du Rafale en
intégrant l'oeil du pilote ou du
navigateur dans le système d'arraphaël
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on fera regarder
race
d'être ici aujourd'hui en salle du coup
ça nous permet d'avoir les retours à
chaud des pilotes de pouvoir répondre en
direct donc aux interrogations qui
peuvent avoir et donc de gagner beaucoup
de temps et de créer des liens de
confiance aussi avec les pilotes et la
on vole ça c'est pas passé exactement
comme on pensait donc l'industrie a été
en salle d'écoute et c'était précieux en
vol de pouvoir discuter avec lui de lui
expliquer ce qu'on voyait pour qu'il
puisse diagnostiquer le souci peut-être
nous donner des clés pour essayer de
contourner le problème ou pas notre
travail justement c'est de réduire ce
nombre d'inattendu de les cartographier
et à terme surtout de les améliorer les
corriger s'ils doivent l'être pour
pouvoir poursuivre la campagne et par la
suite fournir une capacité pleinement
opérationnelle aux forces
Guillaume et Magali vont continuer les
essais jusqu'à maîtriser les risques
avant la livraison de ce rafale F4 aux
armées
les savoir-faire de DGA essai de
missiles permettent de réaliser des
tests sur des engins balistiques
un des équipements spécifiques du Rafale
F4 c'est le missile Mika nouvelle
génération
le missile qui est employé par les
forces sur le Rafale il va falloir qu'il
puisse l'utiliser en toute sécurité et
pour ce faire il va falloir vérifier que
le missile sa structure est capable de
supporter cet effort d'éjection appliqué
par le lance-missile situé sous le
Rafale et c'est cette éjection avec
toutes les contraintes associées que
nous allons réaliser justement dans
cette dans cette tour de chute il y a
deux façons de propulser le missile Mika
nouvelle génération soit en bout d'elle
ou bien sous le fuselage du Rafale
sur le site Gironde ingénieur et
technicien s'affairent autour du bon
décès EB3 une tour de 21 mètres de haut
qui permet de simuler la chute d'un
missile la grande particularité qu'offre
cette tour c'est d'avoir des grilles
très solides permettant d'éviter aux
spécimens donc par exemple à un
propulseur de s'échapper de l'air si
toutefois il venait être initié voilà
donc ça c'est infrastructures qui sont
très appréciées par nos partenaires
industriels puisque toute la sécurité
d'emplois des spécimens en essai et
garantis par expertise de la DGA cet
essai il a nécessité une grosse phase de
préparation en amont un an et demi à peu
près de définition d'un portique qu'on a
fixé dans la tour de chute dans laquelle
on travaille c'est un essai de des
risques caches c'est à dire qu'on le
fait en amont avec une maquette avant de
passer sur l'essai avec un propulseur
actif pour essayer de trouver des
solutions à tous les problèmes qu'on
peut avoir là en amont sur cet essai
afin de simuler un tiers de Rafale en
haute altitude le Mika nouvelle
génération est placé dans un congélateur
jusqu'à atteindre une température
négative extrême
quelques heures plus tard le missile est
sorti de son caisson réfrigérant les
équipes des ga ont 30 minutes pour
réaliser les sets
dans ce laps de temps très court les
techniciens accrochent le missile au
lanceur il place un matelas en dessous
pour ne pas endommager la maquette
l'alerte est donnée et tout le personnel
se replie à plus d'un kilomètre de
distance
si je l'enlève les bouchons je peux
envoyer des gens dans la tour si je mets
les bouchons je peux plus les envoyer à
toi
ça bloque vraiment c'est vraiment une
barrière de sécurité les éléments qui
retiennent mon attention c'est notamment
donc les bouchons de sécurité qui sont
un élément indispensable pour que mes
personnels soient en sécurité pendant
les actions qui vont mener dans la tour
on fait un essai déjection donc on a
quand même des risques serait-ce que la
maquette si jamais elle arrivait à
chuter du coup les bouchons permettent
quand ils sont mis qu'il n'y ait pas
d'ordre qui puisse être passé ni par le
poste de commandement de tir ni par les
équipes MBDA pour éviter qu'il y a un
problème
[Musique]
les caméras ultra rapide situé tout
autour du dispositif doivent permettre
d'exploiter à distance les données de
l'essai c'est l'objectif principal
3 2 1 top numéro
donc c'est pour ça pour moi je veux pas
prendre de risques du tout je manip et
que le deal
on s'est rendu compte autour de ces
déroulement que nos caméras ultra rapide
n'enregistraient pas quand on envoyait
l'ordre d'enregistrement et sachant
qu'en fait c'est caméras sont des
mesures qu'on appelle prioritaire parce
que elles permettent ensuite de
reconstituer la trajectoire du missile
une fois qu'il est jeté et donc le
directeur d'essai en coordination avec
la sociale d'essayer les autres équipes
on a appris la décision de pas aller au
tir tant que ce problème là n'était pas
résolu puisque ça fait partie des
mesures qui sont très importantes pour
nous pour ensuite analyser les
performances du SL bien sûr on aurait
préféré tirer ce matin après ça fait
partie de l'essai on va investiguer cet
après-midi et puis on va essayer de
trouver d'où vient le souci pour pouvoir
aller à laisser de manière optimale
journée difficile pour Floriane et ses
équipes mais c'est justement leur
persévérance qui enrichit les protocoles
de test
quelques jours plus tard tous les
capteurs de mesure sont fonctionnels les
sels à son terme et donnent des
informations précieuses quant à
l'éjection du missile par le Rafale F4
[Musique]
sur la base aérienne 118 de
Mont-de-Marsan les militaires se
préparent à accueillir un nouvel avion
de chasse
il s'agit du Rafale F4 sur lequel le
binôme de DGA est en vol a effectué des
tests et que Magali vient livrer au
centre d'expertise aérienne militaire le
CEAM
on travaille en équipe constituée et la
preuve en est comme vous avez pu le voir
il y a le conseiller DGA du général
commandant le CEM qui est en ce moment
dans mon bureau et avec qui on échange
au quotidien pour avancer sur de
nombreux dossiers parmi lesquels figure
le standard F4 du Rafale
identique désormais les personnels
navigants du centre d'expertise aérienne
militaire vont pouvoir réaliser des
tests opérationnels autrement dit ils
vont véritablement évaluer ce dont ce
nouveau rafale F4 est capable pour le
combat aérien
les améliorations qui sont apportées par
le standard nous permettent d'avoir une
meilleure connaissance de la situation
tactique de mieux nous adapter ça nous
permet aussi de mieux communiquer avec
nos armements et enfin d'être mieux
protégé
en vol va inviter des personnels de mon
équipe à venir voler pour faire des vols
de constat des vols dans lesquels on va
mettre l'avion dans une situation
opérationnelle but étant que on puisse
faire une photographie du développement
de l'avion savoir où il en est et
éventuellement discuter avec les
industriels des derniers ajustements des
modifications qui seraient vraiment
nécessaires pour aller jusqu'à la
qualification sereinement
en quoi est-ce un confort pour nos
forces de première ligne et bien c'est
que chacun son métier et elle elles ont
pas du tout à se soucier de la fiabilité
du matériel et de ses capacités de
comment les utiliser au mieux tout ça ça
a été fait en amont à la fois par les
équipes de la DGA et puis par nous CEAM
qui vont fournir le mode d'emploi tout
ce qu'on fait c'est pour l'utilisateur
final qui est le militaire c'est pour ça
qu'on travaille beaucoup avec les
questions d'expérimentation des armées
parce que c'est le lien naturel entre le
système qu'on finit de qualifier et le
système que eux vont récupérer ensuite
pour faire des évaluations
opérationnelles
cet appareil est sorti d'usine mais
qu'en est-il des anciens rafales jusqu'à
quand pourront-ils voler quelles sont
leurs limites pour trouver des éléments
de réponse à ces défis techniques la DGA
utilise des structures innovantes
très forte ce sont des projets ambitieux
techniquement et donc notre défi à nous
c'est de pouvoir intégrer des
innovations technologiques à cycle très
courts dans des opérations à cycle très
longs je pense que l'innovation
technologique elle fait partie de l'ADN
de la légère
c'est à Toulouse berceau de
l'aéronautique depuis que Clément Ader a
inventé le premier aéronef que la DGA a
implanté son centre d'essai technique
aéronautique
dans ce centre sont testés tous types
d'avions civils et militaires dont le
Rafale mais également les équipements de
vol
parmi eux le casque que porte les
navigants c'est un élément crucial en
raison des contraintes physiques
exercées lors d'une éjection de cockpit
la moindre modification des équipements
même infime peut avoir de grosses
conséquences sur la sécurité du
personnel à bord en fait ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est quand on s'éjecte par
exemple sur rafale on va subir une
accélération entre 10 et danger et donc
finalement le poids du casque va prendre
une importance
pour mener à bien ces tests le centre
d'essai technique aéronautique peut
compter sur une technologie quasi unique
au monde on se trouve ici même dans
l'installation d'essai une blast c'était
donc une soufflerie impulsionnelle qui
reproduit le choc aéronique quand le
pilote va passer la verrière on est sans
même de la soufflerie puisque c'est ici
même qu'on va piloter ses essais
cette soufflerie a été mise en service
dans les années 90 elle comptabilise
plus de 3500 essais ce qui représente
près d'une centaine par an
aujourd'hui on a on a vu un casque vol
rafale standard
on a déjà en fait qualifié le standard
F4 avec le viseur de casque Thalès donc
ça c'est quelque chose qui est
installation a été quand même des essais
associés qualification de ce nouveau
dispositif on se doit d'avoir une
réponse technique pour répondre aux
enjeux d'aujourd'hui mais surtout aux
enjeux futurs on a décidé de développer
un banc d'essai qu'on associe au wimbled
en fait c'est un rail d'éjection qui est
positionné devant la soufflerie qui va
reproduire la composante ascensionnelle
de l'éjection dans ces tous premiers
instants c'est quelque chose qui est
absolument unique au monde par son
architecture technique je me tire
toujours c'est meilleur en général je
travaille pour la surveiller pilotes de
chasse en tout cas c'est comme ça que
j'explique aux gens moi j'ai à cœur
voilà j'ai à cœur de bien faire mon
métier autre spécificité de ce site les
hall concordent et Airbus la cellule et
c'est fatigue éprouve les avions en
soumettant un vieillissement accélérer
des ailes parfois même jusqu'à la
rupture pour vérifier les marges de
sécurité les industriels vont mesurer
leur système
juste pour que ça marche nous on va
prendre ces systèmes et on va aller les
pousser jusqu'au moment où ça ne marche
plus pour aller voir jusqu'où on peut
aller
ce serait d'aller regarder comment on
peut faire pour
démonter un vérin qui est à l'extrado et
au plus près d'implantur
la modélisation de cette structure en
trois dimensions autour du Rafale à
demander 4 ans de travail aux ingénieurs
du bureau d'études ensuite les
techniciens ont créé la structure
métallique et peuvent désormais la
modifier
donc en fait c'est le vérin c'est le
Birk Z2 qu'il faut que vous démontiez et
donc regarder ce qui va falloir démonter
un amont pour pouvoir sortir le vérin et
je m'entoure de tous les acteurs
nécessaires au bon fonctionnement de
l'essai dès qu'on a en charge un essai
en fait on monte une équipe projet qui
sont le bureau d'études qui sont le
l'entité montage entité hydraulique
l'entité pneumatique le pilotage de
l'essai les mesures en essai je suis un
peu le chef d'orchestre effectivement de
toutes ces entités qui viennent
intervenir
pour répondre aux demandes d'essai les
techniciens hydroliciens peuvent se
rendre dans la cathédrale un parc à
vérin où ils vont piocher parmi les 1500
pièces entreposées là actuellement on
m'a demandé justement un vérin d'une
course de 2 m comme celui-ci pour un
autre essai donc le service à côté de
service montage va le récupérer pour
après pour l'installer et c'est un parc
très riche que l'on a comme ça on peut
répondre à différents demandes que ce
soit pour nous en tant qu'hydrolicien on
pourrait répondre vraiment à tous les
différents efforts possibles mais aussi
pour le bureau d'études pour les
différents ingénieurs ils peuvent avoir
comme ça un catalogue très varié sur un
petit cadavre comme ça on a pour deux
trois heures et on a des plus gros
calibres qui vont prendre beaucoup plus
de temps et après ça prend en compte
aussi le côté ce qui va être réparation
des joints nettoyage et tout ça plus la
phase de test comme là actuellement avec
cette machine qui prend qui est vraiment
un petit peu le temps tous les jours on
découvre des nouvelles choses donc c'est
vraiment enrichissant à présent le vérin
défectueux est réparé et les essais
peuvent se poursuivre régulièrement la
DGA et l'industriel
réalise des inspections
bonjour ça va bien et toi ça se passe
comment donc je contrôle le bord
d'attaque du Rafale donc c'est les
rivets qui sont tout le long on utilise
les ultrasons qui permettent d'aller
dans la matière comme les échographies
donc je vérifié si les fixations ne sont
pas cassées
[Musique]
mais après le travail de la cellule et
c'est fatigue il se retrouve aujourd'hui
être le plus vieux de la flotte nous
avons la nécessité de maintenir une
feuille de route crédible pour
l'aviation de chasse française tout ceci
montre que c'est un travail en continu
avec l'industrie pour pouvoir arriver à
avoir des équipements qui nous
permettent d'éviter ce qu'on appelle les
ruptures de capacité opérationnelles il
se trouve que le Rafale est un excellent
avion j'ai tout confiance dans le fait
qu'il sera capable d'aller au-delà de
son potentiel donc oui ça donne de la
souplesse ça donne une flotte
riche qui permet d'attendre les nouveaux
systèmes qui arriveront à l'horizon 2035
2040 à cet échéance le Rafale
n’appontera certainement plus sur le
porte-avion Charles de Gaulle mais bien
sur un autre mastodonte des mers
initialement installé à Paris au cœur de
l'actuel ministère des armées DGA
technique hydrodynamique désormais situé
en Normandie est un des plus vieux
centres d'essais il a participé à la
construction de nombreux navires grâce à
des moyens uniques en Europe nous sommes
au sein du bassin de traction Emile
Barillon qui est un bassin de environ
600 mètres de long 15 mètres de large 7
mètres de profondeur ou en test
différentes maquettes à l'intérieur de
par ces dimensions et ses
caractéristiques ce bassin est quasi
unique en Europe et parmi les meilleurs
du monde en termes de performance en
fait c'est un bassin de traction
c'est à dire que c'est une énorme
piscine au dessus de laquelle il y a une
plateforme qui peut rouler sur des rails
le long de la piscine et qui tractent
des maquettes comme celle-ci sur ce
bassin navigue à faible vitesse un engin
de près de 11 mètres de long il s'agit
de la maquette du prochain porte-avion
nouvelle génération afin d'étudier sa
manœuvrabilité la maquette est bardée
d'une multitude de capteurs de mesure et
de plusieurs hélices la vie d'une hélice
entre guillemets ça commence dans le
bureau de l'ingénieur quand on reçoit le
cahier des charges toute la phase de
conception qu'on transforme on crée la
géométrie on la transforme pour qu'elle
soit adaptée une fois que c'est figé ça
part ici chez nous au bureau d'études
qui qui sort les plans de l'hélice et
une géométrie bien propre pour que ce
soit exploiter par les techniciens et
vous voyez et c'est eux qui vont
fabriquer à l'échelle réduite une hélice
pour
donc ici vous avez donc une des pales
qui va venir construire l'hélice si on
veut utiliser de la machine-outil
on risque de créer des arrêtes ou de
manger la forme beaucoup plus vite on le
souhaiterait plus élice et moins l'eau
viendra accrocher sur le propulseur il
est vraiment nécessaire oui de
travailler manuellement plutôt que
d'utiliser
à une machine outils cet outil c'est un
outil qui est fabrication maison c'est
une transmission de savoir-faire et pour
gratter n'a pas trouvé l'équivalent dans
le commerce une fois toutes ces étapes
terminées on va aboutir à un résultat
comme celui-ci le polymiroir on est bien
sur une surface lisse et homogène
j'ai toujours été frappé par la
complémentarité effectivement entre les
ingénieurs qui vont faire des choses
extrêmement techniques pointues
sophistiquées et des artisans
d'exception qui également du point de
vue de la technique vont faire des
choses extrêmement pointues et
sophistiqués c'est l'alliance des deux
qui nous permet effectivement de faire
des choses qui sont relativement uniques
en plus des futurs standards rafales le
porte-avion nouvelle génération
accueillera à son bord des drones de
combat tous ces éléments collaboreront
et communiqueront ensemble c'est ce que
la DGA appelle l'hyperconnectivité et le
SCAF pour système de combat aérien du
futur en sera un des piliers pour vous
donner une idée le porte-avion de
nouvelle génération quand il sera mis à
la mer en 2036 ou 2037 on sera plus à 5G
on va être peut-être à la 15g ou
communication quantique c'est
aujourd'hui que l'on doit préserver de
la place dans ces opérations pour
intégrer ces innovations qu'on ne
connaît pas encore
alors le combat collaboratif c'est
l'avenir du combat dans tous les
domaines naval terrestre aérien
effectivement le système de combat
aérien du futur c'est quoi c'est un
avion de nouvelles génération qui est
entourée délié dronisés qui vont donc
communiquer entre les capteurs les
efflecteurs qui vont pouvoir s'échanger
de l'information grâce notamment au
plateau de simulation SCAF et
laboratoire connectivité la DGA
permettra aux forces opérationnelles
d'avoir une meilleure perception du
champ de bataille dans son ensemble en
effet la gestion et le partage de flux
d'informations de plus en plus important
sont également des enjeux majeurs pour
les armées
ces hommes et femmes qu'ils soient
ingénieurs militaires ou techniciens
ouvriers font preuve d'audace et on
recourt à l'innovation pour assurer la
sécurité des armées et cet objectif est
atteint en grande partie à travers
l'implication de la dizaine de centres
d'expertise et d'essai de la DGA si on
n'avait pas nos centres d'essai nous
sommes d'expertise et décès puisqu'il y
a beaucoup d'experts techniques qui sont
à l'intérieur de ces centres on ne
pourra pas réaliser cette mission aussi
bien qu'on l'a fait aujourd'hui donc ces
centres d'essai c'est le gage de
l'autonomie stratégique de la France en
matière de système d'armes la France se
prépare désormais à contrer de nouvelles
menaces dans les champs cyber et
cognitif dans les grands fonds marins ou
encore dans l'espace
de nouvelles zones de conflictualité que
la DGA a également investi avec toujours
un seul objectif préparer la défense de
demain
[Musique]